[Music]
this is a show where I remembered
talking to cast members on The Sopranos
when that show was on interviewing them
and they would say we're so afraid
because any week we could get the call
from David Chase that our character is
going to die or or people unlost were
afraid that JJ Abrams that they get the
phone call your character gets killed
next week this the deaths are so
surprising how do you handle that
because on your show you never know
which character is gonna go no it's so
funny because we at the beginning of
season 2 Glenn called to talk about
character changes and stuff that were
gonna happen and they say no don't worry
don't worry you know I'm not it's not
that cool I was like which cool he goes
well you know everybody gets so scared
when I call you and you know that it's
gonna be the death call and stuff and I
was like I wasn't even thinking that but
now every time my phone rings that's
exactly what I think when he calls him
like you know so I put it in a bucket of
for Darrin for me cause you just you
junk it in the fishbowl yeah I like
you're getting called by a Brooklyn
bookie do you think they would tell you
in advance would they warn you if your
character was going on yeah they do but
I send them so many presents so doesn't
matter
yeah no you just don't pull out Val
Kilmer on the show and then you what do
you mean about that
I mean you behave yourself oh yeah yeah
oh like she's telling you anything you
don't know
everyone's like that val kilmer even val
kilmer at home knew what you meant yeah
Kilmer said oh she's right wearing
antler ears naked yeah because he almost
played someone on the show that's not
true
please start some rumors while you're
here yeah very quickly we don't have
much time but I have to ask you Chloe
are Bardem was just here and he's
playing my opinion one of the great Bond
villains of all time you ever think
about maybe would you want to play a
Bond girl you're so beautiful you're a
great tough you know hater
you know I would love to do a bond thing
where you were where you were a boy the
whole time and you were some kind of
kung fu kick us boy and then you realize
that you're you have short hair and at
the end you realize you're a woman and
you have mad sex with bond or something
but if she's a boy or girl that's what
it sounds like
[Applause]
Oh
that's a real twist yeah no freaking
idea
and Glen Mazzara school I would watch
that film i watch you do anything